اكد قيادي في حزب المؤتمر الوطني السوداني
المنحل خروج عدد من اهم قيادي الحزب من
سجن كوبر بسبب تفجر الاوضاع الامنيه في
البلاد كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات اين يمكن وضع خروج قياديين
بارزين من نظام الرئيس المعزول البشير من
السجون ضمن السياق العام للتطورات
الميدانيه كيف تعاملت اطراف الازمه مع هذا
المعطى في ظل حاله الفرز الحاد والدام
الذي تشهد البلاد وما الذي ستؤول اليه
التوازنات السياسيه والميدانيه في البلاد
بالنظر الى تجدد القتال وغياب افق للتسويه
السياسيه
يعني هنالك ظروف يعني صعبه جدا مره
للسجناء بالنسبه للتفاعل الغذاء
والكهرباء والمياه بضطر عدد من السجناء او
كل السجناء بهذه السجون للخروج من هذه
يعني السجون يعني ما حدث اخرج ايضا
السجناء السياسي ان قد تكون هنالك عياده
عيادي سياسيه داخل داخل السودان او داخل
المؤسسات العسكريه تريد يعني من خروج
هؤلاء المعتقلين السياسيين زياده المشهد
تعقيدا على النار الظروف واضحه هي
الفوضى التي سالت الخرطوم في الايام
الماضيه اصبح السجن غير امن على المعتقلين
المعتقلين السياسيين وخاطب المحاربون
محاوله هؤلاء الاخوه المعتقلين الدوله
واداره السجون في ضروره توفير مكان امن
لهؤلاء المرتغلين حتى لا يلحق بهم ضرر
ولكن لم يتم هذا الى ان جاء
الحراسه هؤلاء المعتقلون وطلبوا منهم
تامين انفسهم بانفسهم باعتبار اصبح خاليا
من الحراسه الرسميه
هي التي تعدد على السجون ولايه الخرطوم
وسدوم في ولايات الغرب هذا ثابت وهناك
الكثير مثل فيديوهات التي توثق خروج هؤلاء
المساجين وشهادتهم بان قوات الدفع سريعه
السيد احمد هارون عندما خرج يعني اصدر
بيانا قال فيه بصراحه انه دعا السودانيين
الى دعم ومسانده الجيش في هذه المعركه ان
كان الامر كذلك ما استفاده قوات الدعم
السريع من اخراج هؤلاء من السجون
سريع ربما اخضع في التقدير يعني
ربما ارادت حتى
الذي حشد هذه الاله العسكريه الكي يفرض
الاتفاق الايطالي ويجبر البرهان على انفاس
هذا الاتفاق الايطالي ثم يقول اننا ضد
القران ولكن وجدوا ان الشعب السوداني كله
يحرك ضدهم باعتبارا للمعرفه ضد القوات
المسلحه معركه خاسره وهم يريدون ان
يتفادوا هذا الفضاء الاعلامي باعتبار
الفضاء قاسم ويريد ان يزج اعلاميا فقط
بالاسلاميين حتى يحاولوا ان يعوضوا خسائر
التعبئه ضد القوات المسلحه باعتبار من
القوات المسلحه هذه المؤسسه قوميه
والاسلاميين مؤسسه يتفق ويختلف عليها
لديها مفهوم ولديها منافسين ولديها اتباع
ممكن ان تخرج ضدها ولكن من الصعب جدا ان
تخرب على القوات المسلحه
فقاعات اعلاميه للتعبئه ضد نظام الحكومه
الانقاذ وهي الان اصبحت ليست جدول الشعب
السوداني الان تجاوز هذا تجاوز هذا
الموضوع الشعب السوداني الان مشغول ومهم
بالفشل المتراكم منذ اربع سنوات
السودانيين الان مفهومين بقضايا المعايش
وقضايا